[Music]
of the week Massa Dennis Borgia and this
time actually we're looking at some of
those important games at the Linda's
Abby challenge which is the continuation
of the Magnus tour as you might know
Magnus has won the previous ones but
this time he's kind of struggling so
we're going to look at a few of his
games that actually struck me as not
just interesting but something that
makes him such a special player so first
off let's take a look at his game
against you young G with the black
pieces so in this game you young G is
playing white and plays d4 which is by
in itself very much of a shocking move
he was known to be an e4 player always
happen but suddenly plays a d4 d5 c4 c6
and naturally calls and Springs a
surprise on him why because he just
doesn't want to run into some home
preparation and switches out up and
plays the Slav namely the semi Slav
favored by many very high-class
grandmasters like Sam Shanklin and also
prominently featured in World
Championship matches namely the Kramnik
Anand matches as Anand single-handedly
defeated Kramnik just by approaching and
playing the semi Slav that the black but
some help there the great grandmaster of
rustam gosh Eames on over 97 Queen c2
we're kind of going that direction in
fact that's not true here III 97 Bishop
d3 was tested in that World Championship
match and the fight
around these critical variations of 86
and early c5 but young-hee plays Queen
c2 and probably he was hoping for
something to happen and it did
cousin played a five so who's playing in
this game this game is between you
young-hee versus Carlson Carlson playing
the black pieces in the Linda's Abbey
challenge this online event that's held
currently so here a five is played by
Colin and this's as most of you might
have known the brainchild of the great
Daniel
dubov Russian Grand Master who's very
creative and comes up ideas such as a
five on move six normally everybody went
for Bishop d6 and castles that was
always considered to be the main line
however he played a five and do above
his ideas the following if white plays
Bishop d3 takes takes b5 Bishop e2 it
should be seven a3 just stopping b4 rook
c8 castles B 4 and C 5 so the main idea
is to build a bigger Center than a 6 and
c5 and just push this a5 bond up so you
can roll those spawns with B 4 and C 5
and black often gets good play which is
kind of given and is considered to be a
good position for black blacks Bishop is
just too strong so white might not be
worse but it's comfortable play for the
black player
so probably at this moment calls and was
happy because he could uncork a five but
I'm pretty sure thank you young he was
just as happy to see a five on the board
why because it is an opening experiment
and it can have a potential downside so
he replied that a for saying I don't
want to see that be five idea of yours
not now not ever
Bishop d6 Bishop e2 Castle castle and
there's two ways of playing this
position you can go b6 and Bishop b7 but
probably realizing cause and realizing
that after b3 we get into a position
already played by Dingley REM they think
exactly against him he did not want to
transpose back to those type of
positions so decided to deviate and play
this DC e5 idea ship C v e5 and if
you're really good at rotating positions
in your head I'll tell you a secret
white is actually playing a French
defense
this is a French structure that is the
French Bishop however this is a better
version of the French because this
bishop is very much useful on this
diagonal it's very active and white has
hopes to build a center of it efore
eventually and conversely black is
actually playing a Knight d2 French set
up with a solid structure the pawns
being on c6 and b7 it's very hard to
attack them so it's very interesting in
chess and often if you're familiar with
other openings you might actually find
those a little bit of similarities
should be to be nice 7h3 so the fight
will revolve around this efore square
now black can't really go efore just
right now because there's no g5
just double attacking triple attacking
to be more exact on the e4 pawn and if
you go here you have seven pawn is just
going to fall now Carlsen doesn't want
to lose the pawn like that she plays
Bishop b4 instead the idea being if
Bishop d2 then he would play e4 Knight
g5 and this doesn't really work because
I can take on c3 takes n h6 just
trapping that night as you can't take on
e4 you have two defenders two attackers
and in general if you don't have more
attackers than defenders and the
defenders hold on to the fort so here
white would be losing so seeing this
youngji decided to take on e5 I take C
594 and Cozens next move is a little
suspicious
however it's not bad but a little
strange he plays c5 she's very
aggressive but it does leave some
squares loose and what actually
surprised me is that yongi action played
night b5 instead of Knight f5 not
claiming that black is not doing fine
because after let's say 9 g6 didn't know
g6 is not that him necessary just rook
the eight stopping this Bishop b2 idea
blacks pieces are so active it doesn't
even matter yet that White has the
bishop there because that bishop on c1
is out of business it's doing absolutely
nada it's not dangerous so that's why I
would have thought that maybe you could
have gone rogue d8 instead go here takes
takes nygean not only you're fighting
this bishop from ever getting out from
c1 e 4 is not possible because after
taking on c3 I will be able to capture
the four pawn so c5 was played
Nighy b5 which I was surprised to see
Bishop e6 Bishop e6
F take c6 and this looks like a weird
structure but this is typical in the
Slav you're trying to bring another pawn
closer to the center
note that this important d5 square is
now covered by the e6 pawn also whenever
white would start roaming down the board
three four F four there's always an e6
pawn holding them off well he does not
have a choice now but he had a choice
not to play Bishop e6 F takes e4 and we
already know what me know you already
know that white wants to play at four so
let's try to think a little bit with
Carlson's head how can we potentially
stop that f4 idea
well you can't really stop it physically
you've got to bring some pieces over
there tonight h5 Chico 97 you're not
actually putting pressure on that square
which is so important but Magnus's move
of night h5 is super good he's
anticipating this pawn to show up on f4
and yes at the moment we can't capture
the pawn because I told you to pieces
defending to attacking that evens out
but black can add an extra attacker and
then the situation can get very dicey
very quickly for you young ji so he
actually side steps that and plays 92
instead 92 but here comes Carlson's big
move and if you're a big fan of Smith's
love you might find this one in a
heartbeat so the black to move and play
a very stylish move it is still
connected to that f4 square so the fight
is still it revolving around this square
or f4
so I'll give you a bit of a hint your
nights are great it's not buying itself
on h5 it does the purpose of kind of
stopping that I've four move but it
would be even better
if it would become an outpost for this
age five night which is kind of sideline
at the moment so indeed g5 is the big
move and what's fascinating about the
slav that you can get away with such
moves because of the closed nature of
this structure g5 is a super strong move
introduced by real champion smyslov
the point is you're not gonna be allowed
to play f4 and if you don't do so I
might be tempted to get my knight on
that for instead also the other idea is
just to start rolling with g5 g4 and
with this Bishop still stuck on c1 there
are some real chances of getting made it
in this type of position so here I think
even though f3 is not the best move I do
think that you young e objectively
should have tried to stop g4 at all
costs but don't get me wrong this is a
very very ugly structure where all of
your dark squares are just super weak or
something you wouldn't like to see and
of course black would be better so your
yongi plays Bishop e3 but now we strike
with g4 9 g3 Queen h4 thanks h5 and
what's fascinating blacks position is so
good but you can even consider it as
piece sacrifice of G takes h3 the King
doesn't really have too many defenders
around although this is not winning
however if wife is not careful plays
Knight g3
there's Knight g4 and after let's say
any random move
h2g2 and clean h2s coming in and the
main is unstoppable
just look at these guys all staring down
White's position
so just by that you can kind of realize
that Young is in big big problems here
I mean trouble beam takes h5f 4 so f4
was not beloved by computers and I
looked at it but to be honest with you
it's probably the best practical chance
according to the computer this position
is so bad for you yongi that it gives a
5 pawn advantage for Magnus Carlsen
that's a lot of pawns but f4 actually
kind of gets some fight gives some
fighting chance for you young e GF 97
and what Chinese grandmasters on players
are very much known for is that they're
very good at complicating games and
that's exactly what the genius youngji
does he goes and messes around tries to
create and provoke some play but here
actually Carlsen blunder is his
advantage away so he won't have a
virtual five-point advantage after the
next move so whenever you look at this
position the first thing would strike me
is that hey there's not enough defenders
for this King and probably cousin was
also hyper focus own is there a way to
crash through on the Kings side but it
turns out that he wanted to win it in a
clean fashion and what I mean by a clean
fashion is he did not want to go and
risk
but here it turns out the best move is
to risk it takes rubgy six and that all
of these pieces lurking around the king
this is the way to mate queen age three
is coming now g4s after that and this is
a just a decisive attack however calls
and goes for the more simple solution
which does work by the way when you get
those technical positions however when
there's just a Spartan war boiling at
the board you can't just take on g2
Queen g2 King gauge 896 will be g8 he
probably figured that this will be good
enough but after Bishop g5 suddenly
Bishop f6 his sort of a mating threat
too thick on g5 p g5 take six so this is
still fine for Magnus however it's not
quite over yet
h4 eight-six Roccat five so let's stop
right here and try to think about a move
for a black now we can't really take on
g5 just yet because our nights hanging
and then we would be down an exchange so
why would have a rook you a bishop and
that's not a good deal white would get
the better of it so we need to decide
where to put this Knight
so dear viewers chat what do you think
where should we post that night and
again just a little bit of a disclaimer
so cousin is still better in this
position but not by much he doesn't have
that five pawn advantage winning attack
he's actually just somewhat better maybe
a point of point worth of an advantage a
point which usually in chess statistics
means upon advantage
yeah knight c6 and id4 would make a lot
of sense you just want to solidify and
create a monster out of that knight on
e5 or even Knight c4
I'm just moving this night to a better
place but he played an ID three and
probably this is where things go
downhill for Magnus because after b3
this night really doesn't have a safe
haven anymore so yes he took took he has
two pieces for the rook
however roopd one is coming and with two
rooks just being so active it's not it
any clearer anymore if white is that
close to winning King g7 rogue d1 is
predicted you can't even get your knight
to be two because then the invasion
would start it's got to stop the
invasion with c4 BC Knight c5 and so far
as a Roth is not ran over because the d7
square is covered rookie 5 still wanting
to get in look-see 8 but it's not a big
deal so far because you can't go King g6
and just take the pawn king g2 new young
is also very familiar the tendencies in
the ante and the main issue that causing
the spacing here it's way much easier to
play this position with white then the
black because the only thing you need to
know is to bring your king up and create
threats against the King for blankets
more complicated you've got to defend
against these checks and also try to
create a passer on the a file you've got
to coordinate that and if you can
probably you can win if you're very
precise or hold the draw Luke c7 rook d8
that is exactly and precisely what you
young he does he gets both of those
rooks in 94 Luke
eight and whenever you see two works on
the eighth or the seventh it means
nothing good for the one suffering from
it might see five and the next move is
probably the most important one for
white let's try to find it Tukey move in
these and games especially especially
important than this one
so one of the issues that white is
facing in this position is the fact that
rooks are clumsy they only take so much
space and so many squares however if
they get a certain helper it'll look
much more like a checkmate
than anything else
please King f3 the King is the most
important piece and also ones that King
arrives on f5 you no longer have an
escape square on e6 which you would have
if the king is not there a for King G
for a three
now checks King up seven King f5 and
danger danger
you can't push that pawn anymore because
you get checkmated 97 but this is
already very bad because g6 check Guinea
7 and e5 and it's game over
so probably instead of pushing the pawn
he should have tried to get denied back
to d7 me somewhere like here 97 get
denied back to f8 and try to create a
fortress but as you all know cousin is
not a fan of fortresses to put it mildly
but here it was too late
after g6 here he 5 the square is taken
and rook e8 is checkmate
therefore Magnus went down to you young
G now as you may know Carlson did
qualify to the next part of this event
this was the qualification session and
just like is an upcoming event in and
for the st. Louis chess club he is a
clutch player as the clutch chess it's
about to happen
let me show how clutch Carlson is so he
is right in his second game where he
faced theyíve at white and what makes
cause and especially clutch is that once
he loses a game he won't stop he won't
back down
until he strikes back and that's
actually one of those things that make
him a true champion let's see what
clutch Ches cousin can show after a
defeat that can be pretty demoralizing
as you saw in the previous game so he
for c5 Knight f3 d6 Bishop b5 check 97a
for this is the calls and team's
favorite move one of calls and team
members the junior champion Ariane tari
also loves it playing this move of a4
Knight f6 Knight c3 a6 Bishop e2 and
here comes the big big question should
black care about a 5 or should he not in
this game black plays b6 saying I don't
want you to play a 5 and if you do I can
just ignore you and play be fun and get
some space on the flank so it goes b6 d4
C takes d4 Queen takes d4 and I do want
to show just a little bit of a detail
let's go back into this position so
famously the Budapest variation is the
fort C takes Queen takes d4 but then
there's knight c6 and your queen is
under attack however let's go back to
the game in this game
the Knight has already moved to these
seven calls and plays d4 C takes D for
Queen takes d4 and you might try to
reach for your knight however it's quite
illegal to put a knight on these seven
to put on c6 you can only put it on c5
and these are those small little details
of super Grandmaster chess that divides
the Grandmaster from the super
Grandmaster in this case this queen is
actually well positioned so Bishop b7
played castle
six rogue d1 in c7 however yes black
managed to build a normal position kind
of a hedgehog like Sicilian position
Carlson realizes that b6 pawn will be a
little bit loose Bishop e3 should be 792
so he's actually heading towards that b6
pawn which is also by the way fixed
there they cannot move if you move it
the pawn would be taken and I just have
too many pieces guarding that square so
there's no way you can't break through
castles knights e4 and now there's just
too many pieces attacking but the fact
is this is much like a neither of type
of position and here comes the saving
move by black and if you're a neither
player I think I'm gonna give you the
floor to try to find the next move for
black
so seemingly lack is in trouble because
my b6 is a big threat however it's not
that tragic just yet if you find very
ease next move
d5 typical freeing move and if it works
you get a very good position as black
just trying his best to strike back if
your opponent is playing on the flank
and we can kind of call this playing on
the flank you can strike in the center
and that's exactly what the young
Chinese grandmasters do or he does plays
d5 he takes Knight takes takes takes
Knight b6 is not such a big deal because
take stakes and their screen take c2 and
black is just doing fine
it's instead calls and goes Bishop f4
and in fact this is one of those things
that makes him such a clutch player he's
still going for complications even
though he might be demoralized he still
wants to get the best of the positions
which is not selling for a draw or
anything less and probably the next move
by Valley was inaccurate he played
between b7 I kind of assumed he should
go Queen c6
however Knight III could be a little
annoying goes Bishop c5 does end up
being wrong because if Knight takes d5
if you take the Queen I d7 check and
you're forked and you lose the whole
town of pieces that's I decided to go
Queen d7 96 just hoping to get the
bishop there and preparing c4 moves she
takes Bishop takes rook c8 that rook was
attacked and here comes a genius idea by
Magnus Carlsen so it's white to move and
come up there's a fairly fascinating
concept
yeah probably they he thought that day's
threats on c2 and threats on g2 that's a
double attack my friend how are you
going to deal with both of them and
Magnus response was I'm not gonna deal
with any of them
I'm just gonna checkmate you but Roque
three rogue g3 so this actually stops
Bishop takes g2 because if you go there
rogue g3 long Rover move by Carlson
hitting the g7 pawn and the bishop and
that's why it's unplayable because you
either get checkmated or you lose the
bishop and seeing that this is kind of
dangerous where you played Queen c6 and
tried to put pressure on the d6 Bishop
but here comes the moment when accuracy
matters and in these cases Carlsen
rarely fails plays rook g3 he doesn't
really blunder that bishop because he
got made it on g7 g6
but here again he does not back down
what did cause and play here the next
one was important because it keeps
reflecting on the weaknesses of blacks
position so next move is key provides
success
clean it for is interesting however note
that there's so many dark square
weaknesses there you might want to use
that now your queen is already optimally
placed on d4 so it needs a helper as you
all know Queens don't win games by
themselves they're either supported by a
bishop or a knight or some other piece
but by themselves they can't check made
the King now Bishop e5 would run into
Knight takes e5 therefore he went Bishop
f4 Bishop b4 could be interesting but he
figures that this Bishop will be even
more useful on this square threading
setting up this beautiful mating concept
he takes c2 Bishop h6 kept six and this
again gets a little dicey now there's no
longer made on g7 however there are
other things to do
it goes rook e1 defends the bishop and
the other reason this was a great
maneuver you don't have these back rank
tactics ever because when you would get
this rook c1 idea my bishop would defend
the back rank and you don't have that
mate Queenie for very sound judgment by
very trying to exchange the Queen's but
will we exchange Queens as Carlsen
would that be a reasonable choice in
this position
not really you do not want to exchange
Queens beat down upon
we do have attacking potential because
we have those bishops but if we exchange
Queens the attack is gone and Blanc does
get enough play he's up I mean they ease
up upon and that could be problem so he
went Queen the one in situ Queen before
help stop here just to talk a little bit
about just psychology so why did calls
and repeat well he gave the option for
very to deviate and get into position
where he does not have to concede so
maybe he will play something else and
then he can continue on freely that his
attack so that's one of the aspects of
psychology there may be winning some
time that's also possible but mostly
showing who's the boss often in chess
they use this as a weapon they realize
that hey I can force you to repeat the
position and you have to bend to my will
and you have to do what I forced you to
do so whenever he is repeating he's
actually just showing that hey I'm the
one in control and you're just waiting
me for to decide if I actually want to
make a draw or not so that's why he's
going to repeat so that's why he
repeated Queen d1 in e4 Queen d1 but
obviously he doesn't do it a third time
because then you stop the clock and
claim that your next move is clean e4
and the game is declared a draw so he
went all the way to a-1 now I know we
kind of thought that the queen is
terrible in the corner however a queen
is just like a long-range sniper it can
shoot all the way to the end of the
board if it gets the
not quite yet because there's a beep on
blocking the view
however for a queen it really doesn't
matter where you post it as long it has
a direction it can work so it's not an
ideal place at the moment however once
this pawn moves it'll be just fine
95 h 4 CH continuing with the plan
everything's Val defended still just
going for H 5 so the reason event to
Queen a1 and nowhere else
is the following a this was the safest
place for the queen bee he still is
hoping to put pressure along that long
diagonal so he had this goal of keeping
the attack going so that's why he put
the Queen on a 1/9 f7 he want to draw
back with the bishop so when you're down
upon but attacking you sewer fire and
need to avoid exchanging pieces so we
should be e 396 Bishop takes b6 mean C
685 and now actually why'd God the pawn
back and he has more than one thing to
celebrate one of the things that he can
celebrate is the fact that he has these
two bishops and are quite strong on b6
and e2
Mike does not really have competition
there he doesn't have those bishops also
who's skiing is safer dear viewers which
King is safer this is important probably
the most important thing to clarify in
this game
well with all of these hanging pawns
like kingside cannot be considered safe
this King on the other hand is quite
happy
so they egos Knight f5 rooks III Queen
b7 and after f3 I have to admit I do
like white position a whole lot much
more than blacks and that's the
difference I think at the moment between
Carlsen ma Yi very is considering and
concentrating on the concrete details of
the position meaning I'm pretty sure
that he calculated okay I'm going to
have pressure on g2 and the pressure on
the h4 pawn however what cousin does is
evaluate the consequences while Vee is
kind of concentrating whether his
actions are justified by my name ponds
so rooks III Queen BC f3 and I take sage
4 and I think they're Yi considered this
position fine for him because he got the
pawn back he's again up a pawn but to be
honest with you and this is kind of one
of the things that I believe in those
two bishops always compensate that pawn
or at least 90 percent of the time so
those bishops do compensate now don't
get me wrong
that is my hypothesis he might be
thinking a different concept but I do
think that taking this pawn was
overrated or not by that good as he
thought it would be before and suddenly
this queen is super useful the screen is
just much better than that night on h4
because that night on h4 apart from
winning the pawn is sideline man is out
of the action as you can kind of expect
rook c1 route
is coming in and that can be a big
problem see five so they II kind of
figured that this should be good enough
however it turns out not to be true
Brooke C 1 and the problem now is too
full
not only does he have to deal with this
a six weakness Brooke C seven F happens
let's say Knight f5 rooks e seven takes
takes Queen b8 just look at those guys
they can't move clean c3 Queen c5 is
come in and if anyone's dominating its
white it's got to dare that Bishop e6
trickery you can even take you can't
take back cuz we'll see a check and
you're lost
so obviously h5 was just a sample move
but even if you go clean f8 I have this
idea of Bishop takes a six
that just shows that you can't even
parry my simple threat a simple cheap
tactics we can call it cheap because it
is looks it lost look like a trick
however it's the position so bad it's
hard to deal with it so you have to take
on c3 Queen takes c3 but the main issue
in this position that once you exchange
you brought the screen back into the
game this queen and rook puts lots of
pressure on the C file you can't put a
rock in front of it and you still have
to deal with ideas of b5 preparing a6
palm pushes in the future so that an
game looks not too blissful if being
frank here not f5 and Coulson's next
move is again staple staple Magnus
so my to move and when now don't expect
a double Bishop sacrifice cuz you won't
find it
but if you play this very nice move your
advantage will be near decisive and
again talking about being clutch clutch
chess is coming up pretty soon
featuring Khurana so Dominguez and many
other players so it's on Tuesday
actually so Queen c7 and what failed him
in the previous game against you young
he actually is the reason why he's going
to succeed in this one he knows the
endgame is perfect he has the bishop
there and if he can start running with
that a pawn
he's just going to succeed so Maya not
exchange Queens 94 Bishop takes d4 takes
takes edy rook d7 now they did make some
progress and he's almost right there to
hold the position however it's not quite
good enough because the king is stuck on
the 8th and once that a pawn rolls up
the board is not much you can do about
it
so with these pieces being so passive
the position is getting very dicey
Bishop c6 rook takes d4 King f7 rook d6
and here actually they threw in the
towel why because you can't go rook c8
yet again it should be 7 runs into room
d7 check you lose the Bishop rook c8
then there's Bishop takes a 6 and these
pawns are just rolling down the board
and it's game over and the best idea
that where you can have in this position
as Bishop b5
but even that is losing because takes
takes will be six and once cousin gets
the second pawn these connected pawns
will just roam down the board and it
just wins automatically other than that
you really don't have any other move to
me
if you move the bishop away you just
drop the a6 lon and you got exactly the
same situation well actually that is the
reason why Colin is playing so well
because he knows the right moment or the
right sequences how to liquidate an
advantageous position into a winning one
and I think in some ways that's where he
are played by ye so I really hope you
guys enjoyed this lecture where I looked
how calls and managed to play some
clutch chess coming back from a loss and
winning just in the next round thank you
so much for watching have a good day or
night wherever you are
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]